*Mac log off sound gentle as fuck
Windows XP Sound :)
AAAAAAAlright everyone, it´s time to continue with the green screen competition (BOOH)
We got a lot - We got so much fucking weird shit (Shit) SHIT
I forgot to turn on my light. I guess the lighting is so good I don't - ey, i don´t need it
I look sparkling and shiny and beautiful and- perfect complex skin anyway :) Thank you very- (You're welcome)
But enough about me! Let´s keep watching the green screen competition submissions.
*Creepy ass music
This is creepy, man.
Fucking pigger (?)
*Intro of the best TV Show 2083* (I need this to be a real show. :D)
Well, that´s a TV show I wanna watch.   (The world is ending)
One Pewds man - alright, alright, alright :D
ONE PUUUUUUAAAAAANNNNCH yeah, baby ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*laughing* EDGAR having a seizure
I wanna have my own anime soo bad!
*Murica flag
Why america? Should be Sweden man.
thi-- fuckin' good shit man ! മ◡മ
*Yo mama vomitting cum
haHAHAH
GET HIM MALCOM!!1!  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Really? it jus--
Thank you, for everyone else submitting, but this one, was clearly this best one.
Jesus Christ.
Pewdiepie meets Zoey. (ZOEY 101 HA, anyone else know what that is..? No?Just me? Okay..) #bigbewbs
jEEEsus Thumbnail! (Kawaii voice though Pewds :D)
Is That Zoey From Left For Dead WHAT THE HELL THAT DOES'NT EVEN MAKE ANY Fuking SENSE
even make any fucking sense
take it back
*Bahhhhh motafuka
"Clap" Take it Back That Was The Winner
that was the winner you know what i'm
going to do with this
you know back
sll-hahaha
oh mama little bit
*clearly enjoying it*
that's a little too hard to be fair
To Be Fair What Was I expecting Honestly I'dont now
why was I expecting honestly I don't
know Oh God attack on titan attack on
Oh God Attack On Titan
Attack on Pewd's
pardes attack on pads go
Attack on p-Haha This Going Be This Going Be Good
it's gonna be good hey uh huh
T Hihih EEEEEHHH oh no  *starts making weird noises*
I'm so sorry didn't mean anything bad i
will just
Pewd's : I am So Sorry Didn't Mean Any Thing Bad I'll Just EH*Kills a lot of people*
Real Pewds:HAHAHA
yeah
"Sad" no
No
HAHAHAHA SO SHIT but so Ggood Hehe
so shit was so good in such filthy frank
with PewDiePie my name and why the fuck
Filthy Frank With Pewdiepie
Dillion The idiot : Propet of MY NAME AND li
that was legit man and lightness huh
Pewdiepie: WTF That look's legit man
Dillion the idiot: OF MY AND LIGHTNESS HUH?
when the phone is on the way that's my
news
Pewds When The Big B0ss hacks you
Pewds: Wait That's My New's
Pewds:"laughing"
Filthy Frank's (exept pewdiepie) : Fuck You Just Got Pranked
"gun shot's and explosion JUST LIKE WAHT WE LIKE "
hey you fuck you prepare to fight
Pewds : Hey you Fuck You PREPARE TO FIGHT
Dillion : Just kill me - Pewds : Sure
WADDUP
Pewds :It's yo boi *While walking in his  fantasies*
Papa Franku : Fuck you
Dillion :Pewdiepie You Want War You Can Have IT
you can have it I mean I pay to watch it
coming this never just like kingdom
I mean I'd pay to watch it
Coming this NEVER JUST LIKE KINGDOM HEARTS 3 HUH "Loud noise"
hearts 3 huh
nice i see what the fuck what the fuck
are you nice
Probbaly another sextape remix
Feel's nice and spicy
Pewdiepie :WTF
WTF
TOP OF THE MORNING TO YO LADIES*While trying to do a Jacksepticeye impression*
oh hello
(Some censored shit of people having sex)
OH WHAT IS THIS(Pewd's OH Hello)
I need to start watching Game of Thrones
stop
I Need To Start watch Watching Game Of Thrones(No no you don't)
(It's even worse when you know they are siblings)
I'm so sorry didn't mean nothing bad i
will look at that time to creep i
I Am So Sorry did'nt mean anything bad i Will Just UH SUBSCRIBE TO PEWDIEPIE
completely anything I got this many sons
Are You Completely Mad?-From the Guy having sex in a Abandoned Ruin
Poods : Where Do You Think I Got This Many Subs
Lady : He Saw us (yeah no shit Sherlock he's not blind....Probbaly not)
now look now prepare to find out huh
No! No Pewdiepie No!
hey another matrix yes agent haha
Ey another Matrix, Yes
Ahahaha
nice lifting
Ahaha
Ahhh nice lip sync
oh no it's still in Malcolm I don't have
the third guys
Oh no it's Dillon and Malcom!*Malcom and friends coming for the teaparty
I don't know who the third guy is
Malcom How dare you show your face around these parts
Malcolm its face around this time
hey OH
Prepare to fight
OH woah
Ahahahaha *Gasps*
so gay
So good
you're doing is taking so long as
superimposed all this shit man
You know it had taken so long to super impose all this shit man
OH WOAH HOLY SHIT
oh whoa holy shit
hey that was so again that was so
fucking yet
Hey eheheheh
That was so good, that was so fucking good.
Thank you Lords
thank you Lord George lewd kiss
George ... Lewd-cas
that's how you get number one on youtube
without magic trick - what they're for
Pft What the ff..
What the fuck?
the party
gentle touch what the fuck am I said oh
my god that looks so good without games
What the fuck!?
I hate pewdiepie
Anything i said - Voice in your head
Oh my god that looks so good, What the hell!?
Game of Subs
that Edgar shot anything I said
That Edgar shot
haha these are so creative i love it so
much fun to go through my god
Arrrrrrahahah
These are so creative I love it
It's so much fun to go through these
Nahaha
Oh my god
oh this is so cool
Oh!* Game pewds grabbing a heart
Pffft
This is so cool
now you know how to defeat me just throw
a Japanese cream asked in my face that
Tahahaha
Ahahaha
I hate the them creams
It's true I hate creams it's disgusting
Now you know how to defeat me
Just throw a Japanese cream mask in my face
That sounds weird but it's true
sounds weird but it's true DP depends
What*Dear Pewdiepie its your landlord*
this is one time I really kicked you out
The reason why i really kicked you out
Aha *Its not because i'm homophobic its because i love you*
it's not because I'm this oh you've said
Matt Janet okay apology accepted what
Oh
Okay
K
Apology accepted what can I say, you still kicked me out though
can I say
you still kick me out though my chases
market play me just towards my destiny
Pewdiepie chases markiplier
Tahahahahahaha
back
I wanted to be longer and now it's an MD
of Finance Freddie's oh it's my laser
Aww I wanted it to be longer
Oh no
It's an MMD of five nights at freddy's
Oh it's malaser
stop now
It makes such awshla-awesome MMDs
it makes such actually awesome remedies
and i gave a shit
I like how you bros- Oh shit, OHH he's coming he's coming!
oh he's coming he's coming
what is the
what is up! Drama Alert Nation!
drama
i'm your host killer
I'm your host. k-k killer *scream*
*Slap*
that's a good chick they say the words
jump-scare of all is PA pies is fun
That's some good shit
They say the worst jumpscare of all is Pewdiepie's ass (so true)
don't know
yeah
what
What?(AAHHHHH)
Holy shit the amount of editing that would go into this
we ship the amount of editing that we go
into this is so some of you flat-out
Oh yeah so some of you flat out stole
stole other people submissions
Other people's submissions
like that's not cool we we know if
you're pulling that shit you get banned
Like that's not cool we, we know if you're pulling that shit
You get banned for it alright
for it all right so have fine
So have fun
What the fuuuck?
what that park
no no no free shit got stopped
Nooooo!
No, no furry shit(Sick e'm boy)
God(Beastiality?)
stop
no
no god damn it when the lion king
soundtrack in the back that's there
God damn it
Then the Lion King soundtrack in the back
That yeah thats, ah-what the-ahaha
that's why would you think of this
WHY WOULD YOU THINK OF THIS!?
ok
mkay * suddenly 911*
yeah
*awkward silence*
and you don't win the competition
You don't win the competition
I'm done oh my gosh kdrama i love
Oh my god K drama!
Ahahaha
I LOVE K DRAMA!
kdrama
do you like me like this
do you like me?
like this?
be honest someone got any money
Yep that was pretty spsp spretty slammen man
yeah that's pretty and sprays climbing
man how's it going bros
How's it going bros.
this is from
This is Peeeeewdiepieeee
Vote Trump
it's not even funny
Vote Hilary...
Ahahahaha
Oh it's not even funny but it's funny
but hits right with a great use of a
Great use of- uhhhhh- three seconds I gotta say
three seconds I gotta say what's up
yep you did it three seconds that takes
that takes talent man
yep
You did it
Three seconds, that takes, that takes talent man
what are you going to be doing you want
to see a magic trick
okay i love a mystery go ahead and do
what it is you do I can fly
oh my god mind it
Oh my god
For fucks sake
Ahahaha
yeah it's good that was really good
YEEHEHESS!
Ahahahaha *gasp* Ahahaha *gasp*
Oh that was good that was really good
45 verses . x oh my lord
Pewdiepie Vs. Pewdiepie, Oh my lord
Is that the Bright- It's Brighton Beach yeah yeah
for the bright its Brighton Beach a
thank you
Tahaha
hey oh oh pretty high winds
Hey
OH!
OH!!
OH!!! Pewdiepie wins!
Oh he's got a combo!
He's got a com-aha
Round two
yeah
Ahahahaha
fully shit that's so good
Holy shit
That's so good
what I do every day
like Oh behind the fuck's that no no it
was great until this point within a
OHHHH
OH!
Oh for fucks sake, No no, It was great until this point(DAMN IT ANOTHER SEX TAPE)
With the amount of shh- like the footage that we gave was so shit
matter of like the footage that we gave
was so shit and that they- youtube.com/savethekiddies
And that they- youtube.com/savethekiddies managed to do that out of that
manage to do that out of that is that's
pretty fucking president man i was gay
That's pretty fucking impressive man
Oh that's good, that's really good
45 mean that actually
Pewdiepie meme.exe
Holy shit
all this shit oh oh yeah nice
Oh!
Oh yeah
Nice
holy shit
Holy shit
for fuck's a here
Oh for fucks sake
Dude that was fucking awesome
that was fucking awesome a spicy me
Mandy
A spicy meme indeed
I loved every single one of these so fun
I loved every single one of these, it's so fun
Thank you so much for submitting to the green screen content-test
thank you so much for submitting to the
green screen content test next one will
Next one will be the Meme contest
be the mean contest
Pewdiepie Meme contest
p pi mean contest it should be in
fucking cluster fuck I'm sure link to
It should be a fucking... cluster fuck(Like everything you do)
I'm sure
Link to that is in the description
that is in description thank you so much
for watching and thank you so much for
Thank you so much for watching and thank you so much for submitting
submitting and as always bros i know you
will do some grouse
And as always Bros I know you will (kisses brofist)... Stay awesome Bros
*BROFIST*
TOP OF THE MORNING TO YOU LADDIES
Ahahaha
that is true he just keep me in the eyes
That is true
He does keep me in the closet
what about this feels hi
what is this I don't know honestly
What is this?
I don't know honestly
Oh
Oh what is this oh my god what the hell
Oh my god what the hell?